RETO MEIER: Today I learned that
every 311 complaint, police,
and fire department incident,
bike share ride, street tree,
and filming location
in San Francisco
is now available in a
BigQuery public data set.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer advocate.
Join me as I explore the city
by the bay with BigQuery.
SF, Fog City, whatever
you want to call it,
it's just a short
traffic-congested drive
up the 101 from here
in Mountain View.
So grab your jacket, and let's
head for the golden city.
Really?
Come on.
In 2016, there were almost
a half million 311 calls
in San Francisco, compared to
over 2 million in New York.
So clearly, there's a lot
less to complain about out
here on the bes--
what?
Per capita?
Oh.
San Francisco, home to
over 800,000 people,
is a city that makes good
use of its 311 service using
the municipal complaints
line, 2 and 1/2 times more
often per capita
than New Yorkers.
The most common complaints
in San Francisco
are for graffiti, and requests
for street or sidewalk
cleaning, while
bulky item pickups
and illegal homeless
encampments are
the fastest growing complaints.
San Franciscans are getting
less easily offended,
with inoffensive
graffiti complaints
on the up, while there's
been a significant drop
in offensive graffiti.
The SFPD data includes more
than two million incidents
since 2003.
So we know that as we
head down Bryant Street,
we should keep an eye out.
Theft from locked cars
accounts for over 17%
of all reported crime
incidents in San Francisco.
And Bryant Street is a notable
hotspot, peaking on Fridays,
with most reports filed at
lunchtime or after work.
This heat map shows
the worst places
to park if you're
planning to leave anything
valuable in your car
and want it to still
be there when you get back.
It turns out a lot of stuff
goes missing here on Bryant.
Nearly 20% of filed
lost property reports
are from Bryant Street.
The best odds for
finding something
is here, over on,
Valencia, where
more than twice
as many items are
found than are reported lost.
Meanwhile, on Haight, the
legalization of cannabis
could see a 7%
reduction in the number
of arrests in the
Haight-Ashbury neighborhood.
In 2016, 26% of all drug-related
arrests in San Francisco
were for marijuana.
But as you can see, drug
arrests are down 62% since 2003,
with only methamphetamine
arrests trending up.
2016 marked the first time meth
became the most common involved
in an arrest here in the city.
With access to details for more
than 120,000 sidewalk trees,
we know that you can
get a taste for Monterey
by visiting Sunset Boulevard,
the leafiest street in San
Francisco.
Home to nearly 1,400 Monterey
pines and Monterey cypress, SF
is a shadier city than
New York, featuring
2,600 trees per square mile,
compared to New York's 2,200.
But they share the London
plane as the most common tree
in both cities.
For cyclists, this
trail along Embarcadero
is the most common path
for Bay Area Bike Share
riders in San Francisco.
After looking at nearly
a million trip records,
we learned that San
Francisco bike sharers
spend an average of
14 minutes per trip,
almost the same as the 15-minute
average for New Yorkers.
We'll blame the steep hills for
the slower average trip speeds
here on the west coast.
The 4 million fire department
service calls show us that
the most common location
for a structural fire is
in the Tenderloin, while the
best place for it to happen,
if its' going to
happen, is in Chinatown,
where the average response
between calling 911 and firemen
arriving at your burning
building is an impressive four
minutes, 30 seconds, compared
to a city wide average of six
minutes and eight seconds.
Big shout out to
the crew of Engine 3
of the 4th battalion, the
fastest engine in the west,
with an average response time
of just over three minutes.
Thanks to the city and county
of San Francisco's OpenData
project, and Bay Area Bike
Share, Google BigQuery's
public data sets now
include over 150 gigabytes
of San Francisco public
data for you to explore.
As always, your first terabyte
of processing is free.
So fire up BigQuery today to
investigate San Francisco.
And share you results
with us, using the Today
I Learned With
Big Query hashtag.
And as always, subscribe
to our channel,
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.